hello and welcome to the session on best
practices to maximize bigquery
performance my name is Jagannath Raya
I'm a product manager for bigquery at
Google I'm pleased to be joined in this
session by Gary stealin a software
engineer at Twitter hello Gary
and Argonne nice to be here today really
glad to have you
we've put together a technical session
for data analysts data engineers and
data scientists in short if you like
sequel you've come to the right place
I'm going to start with a quick overview
of the bigquery architecture that drives
the performance you see in bigquery then
we'll walk through a typical query
execution within bigquery
next we'll cover some of the best
practices and how to write fast and
efficient queries and we'll also cover
data processing techniques on the best
ways to get data into bigquery then I
will turn it over to Gary who will show
how Twitter uses bigquery and we'll
share some of his performance tips shall
we dive in customers around the world
rely on bigquery performance to run
their business Spotify which is a global
leader in music streaming analyzes
hundreds of petabytes of data to give
you the most personalized song
recommendations their analytical queries
went from 16 minutes to 33 seconds after
moving to bakery HSBC is a global
financial institution serving 40 million
customers worldwide they were able to
speed up their country liquidity
calculations from hours to minutes and
run their financial and crime analysis
ten times faster with bigquery ups the
largest package delivery company in the
world collects a billion data points
into bigquery every day and have used it
to optimize their truck routes saving
400 million dollars and 10 million
gallons of fuel each year so let's
explore how bigquery can help drive
performance with these businesses and
businesses such as yours so what makes
bigquery special it starts with the true
separation of storage and compute which
allows you to store petabytes of data in
storage but pay pennies per day for your
queries data is stored in Colossus which
is bigquery schölermann are storage
which is encrypted replicated and
distributed making it highly durable
against failures when you send your
queries to bigquery they run in stages
or a massive form of compute units
called slots which are units of
computational capacity
bigquery automatically calculates how
many stages are needed for every query
I'm dynamically calculate the slots
needed for each stage data moves from
the storage to the query server at
lightning speed over the development
scale network called Jupiter Network
even complex queries which need to store
data between the query stages have a
persistent store called shuffle which is
entirely in memory all of these put
together is what makes bigquery
delivered blazing fast performance to
you now we'll take a look at a sample
query to see how it works within the
bigquery architecture this is an example
of a scan filter aggregate query on a
table containing 1 billion page view
logs from Wikipedia when the title
contains Google the queries are first
round into a query master which contacts
the metadata server to figure out
exactly where the physical data resides
and how its partition to come up with
the initial execution plan the first
stage of this query sends the query to a
lot of power workers each of which reads
the title column and filter out the data
that don't match it then does a partial
aggregation as directed by the group by
and writes the results into shuffled
using the hash of the title the next
stage reads from the shuffle output from
the previous stage and does the final
aggregation the final stage of saves 3
is extremely simple it just reads the
resulting titles and stores them in an
alphabetical descending order this final
sort operation is done on a single
worker for serving up the results to the
cond
now that we know how bigquery runs
queries let's look at some of the best
practices and how to run these queries
fast and efficient within Vickery a
typical query consists of a select from
where and group by and order by clauses
since bigquery is a corner store we're
going to start off with how to optimize
selects select star may actually drive
up your cost if you have a really wide
table with lots of columns so the first
tip I have for you is to use only the
necessary columns in your select clause
instead of select star
next when using functions consider using
approximate functions such as a proxy
and distinct or approximate cuantas
insert the corresponding exact functions
such as count distinct upon tells these
approximate functions produce results
which are 99% accurate if you're looking
for trend data and not report exact
values such as from mentioned data now
we'll come to where the where clause is
where you can drive a lot of query
optimization and efficiency the key to
improving efficiency is to filter early
and use predicates which can be pushed
down into the tables to filter out data
especially when joining multiple tables
use the column directly to match values
is a lot more efficient than applying a
function on a column master value since
this predicate can be pushed down next
we'll come to joins in the where Clause
any complex query involving joining one
or more tables and finding magic
relationships through the join columns
there are different types of joints such
as inner join cross join left and right
join which are well known speaking of
how they're executed joints are executed
in bigquery in several ways a broadcast
join is very a large table on the left
is joined with a small table on the
right of the joint in bigquery a
broadcast joint takes a small table and
sends the entire table to every worker
working on the large table column values
if the table on the right is
sufficiently small to achieve this
efficiency you may need to filter and
aggregate the data from the small table
before joining with the large tables the
other type of joint executors within
bigquery is a hash join where you're
joining a large tables now this is
computationally more intensive the goal
of the hash join optimization is to
ensure balance data distribution across
the join tables so keep an eye out for
data skew to give an example of data
skew the number of cricket players per
capita is skewed to the 12 member
countries of the International Cricket
Council versus the countries in the rest
of the world
when this happens you may need to curry
the skewed data separately from the
other data and combine the results using
Union to maximize the efficiency of the
query a special case of join is self
join when a data is shown within itself
this type of query can get very
expensive some of the techniques you can
use to get the data efficiently is to
first take one pass at it so for example
if you have a table containing a male
and female baby names you can use an if
function to create pseudo columns and
compute both sets of aggregates in one
pass another option if you have multiple
records with dependent data for example
it start and end time and date for bike
rides you can use the lead and live
functions just to specify a window
within which your fun to find the
matching entry to understand how these
queries work it is important to look at
the actual execution plan the execution
plan for the query is available under
the execution details for every query in
the bigquery user interface it shows you
the stages that the query took and
provides the details of the operations
and timings at each stage look for the
weights which indicates the stage that
is waiting for independent stage to
complete which can often be a source of
delight you also look for variances
between the average and maximum worker
timings this indicates that the
distribution of work across the workers
may not be uniform now that you've
identified query inefficiencies what can
you do to improve them
bigquery provides several data
organization techniques just
partitioning and clustering to speed up
your query and lower the cost
partitioning in bigquery allows you to
divide large tables into smaller logical
tables called the partitions data for
one partition is stored in a physically
separate location from the other
partitions each with its own metadata
when a query is issued representing a
specific partition value big querying
only scans those logical tables not
matching the partition value instead of
the entire table partitions are usually
designed for low cardinality fields
which is feels
the lower number of distinct values
generally of the order of a few thousand
clustering is a another form of is a
different form of stored optimization
within bigquery that stores the data in
a semi sorted format based on the
cluster key which may consist of one or
more columns you can use a combination
of partitioning and clustering to
optimize your query by identifying the
low cardinality and high cardinality
columns as canvas for partitioning and
clustering we recently announced support
for partitioning of non partition tables
so you can speed up key lookups why even
high cardinality data which are not
partitioned such as user IDs in addition
to looking up queries you can also
improve the cost and efficiency of DML
operations through partition pruning by
using the underscore partition time
pseudo column for ingesting time
partition tables or by using the table
or timestamp column for partition tables
in your DML statement the final
recommendation for curie speed-up is the
use of materialized views MBI engine
materialized views are pre computed
views that cache results of a query for
increased performance and efficiency
bigquery leverages the pre computed
results from materialized views to would
deliver the results if the data changes
bigquery only reads the Delta changes
from the base table to compute the
latest results which is much more
efficient bigquery is also smart enough
to detect when a curry can benefit from
a materialized view and automatically
redirects the query to the cache results
of materialized view instead of querying
the base table from storage bi engine
takes the speed improvement
by drawing an in-memory store for
bigquery to enable this just reserve the
BI engine memory capacity in the same
location is intensive and that's it
your queries will now run fast and
always fresh to store and manage data
you need to bring data into bigquery
Vickery supports batch and streaming
methods of data ingest data can be
loaded into bigquery from a variety of
storage formats ranging from abroad to
JSON you can even use DML to perform
Elte to transform data
using the query API we remove the limits
of the number of DMLs a table can
process per day which is much more
beneficial to you now and is much more
useful if you need to perform continuous
ingest you'll need to use the streaming
API to get more real-time information if
you need really accurate data that is
still in the streaming buffer of
partition tables you can use an
additional clause of underscore
partition time is null define the data
that is in the buffer finally we come to
automation within bigquery
while we have various ETL tools such as
cloud composer and they refusing to
perform various types of ETL sometimes
it may be more efficient to use bigquery
to run complex ETL operations bigquery
supports scripting by which you can run
a series of commands in a specified
sequence with control logic such as
while and in and if you want to save
these you can save these as a reuse of
program called a stored procedure it can
also be used for migrating existing
stored procedures from legacy databases
when you bring them into big queries
this allows you to perform your in data
in their warehouse operations quickly
without having the overhead of having to
move the data outside with this let me
now turn it over to Gary to tell us how
bigquery best practices are used at
Twitter Thank You Jacqueline my name is
Gary and I'm a software engineer at
Twitter today I'm going to talk about
how we use bigquery and Twitter and some
of the specific use cases we have and
some of the performance results that
we've seen from using big queries and
optimization features so the first I
want to go ahead and just dive right in
and talk about how we use bigquery at
Twitter it's important to understand the
scale at which we use bigquery and
Twitter we have hundreds of different
users running queries and jobs every
month they're using or they're running
tens of thousands of jobs every day most
of which are queries we store data and
run queries in hundreds of different GCP
projects with thousands of different
data sets storing hundreds of petabytes
of data as you might imagine processing
amount of data uses a lot of compute
power and we're using over a million
slot hours a day you it's important to
note that at this scale in Twitter
that's why we care about performance so
much every little bit of performance
optimization we can make helps quite a
lot so now let me talk about some of the
different actual use cases we have from
bigquery and Twitter we can think of
these broadly in two different
categories analytics projects and
adoption projects the analytics projects
you see here I'll get into a little bit
more detail later but the adoption
projects are ones that we can think of
as already existing and migrating from a
previous platform over to bigquery so
for example people are migrating from
Google sheets and Google Apps scripts or
on-premise Vertica and solar clusters or
even using Google Analytics and moving
their use cases to bigquery teams who
are adopting bigquery are looking for
big gains in performance and also
maintainability they're also looking for
that rich integration with GCP tooling
so now let me talk a little bit about
those analytics projects in more detail
and some of the performance gains that
we've seen for those analytics use cases
it's important to frame this discussion
by understanding how we look at these
optimizations at Twitter we look at them
at three different levels kind of a
query level table level and the project
level and a lot of those different
features that you saw jugend talked
about earlier you can see here
categorized into the different
categories we make heavy use of all of
these optimizations because of our scale
at Twitter every little bit counts we
also use the project level optimizations
quite a bit such as slot reservations
and workload isolation we try to
separate workloads into separate
projects so we don't end up with noisy
neighbor problems so now that we have an
overview of how we think about these
features at Twitter let's talk about how
we actually use them in some of these
different types of projects
the first one I'll talk about today is
this marketing project the goal of this
project is to generate an internal
dashboard based on some filters where
the results of this report will actually
be used to drive marketing insights and
strategies entirely generating this
report requires running multiple
bigquery queries for each of the
different sections of the report so here
some of the first optimizations we made
were to partition the input tables by
time and to give the project more query
slots to use these two steps
partitioning the input tables by time
and giving the project more query slots
are generally our very first two steps
every time the reason is because these
are very low effort and very high impact
steps we will do this across most
projects here we also cluster the input
tables by user IDs because that's what
the report is keyed on and we also
scheduled a projection of necessary
columns out of the source tables and
into a destination table in that
destination table we also join in a
couple additional columns just so all of
the data for this particular report is
available in one table ready to go
having all your data in one table like
that is actually a huge speed-up just in
and of itself as part of this we also
help this team clean up their queries by
making small tweaks here and there such
as removing unnecessary order by clauses
all these things together resulted in a
33% faster average query time and a 45
percent faster end-to-end report
generation time for this use case the
next use case that I'll talk about today
is the AV experimentation project this
team was are already has an analytics
use case running on premise in Vertica
so in this case we're migrating from an
on-premise Vertica cluster into bigquery
the goal of this each case is to fetch
the results of AV experiments on the
twitter product and render those in a UI
users of the UI will actually use the
insights they gained from the UI to
drive product
the interesting thing here is that the
table that powers this UI has the high
hundreds of terabytes of data in one
place we also have a very low latency
requirement because this is powering an
internal dashboard so here we partition
these input tables by time again and
gave it more query slots to execute
again we do this for almost every
project we also clustered these tables
by more than one IV like Jugend
mentioned you can cluster by more than
one field and we want to do this in
order of highest cardinality first to
eliminate the most amount of data in a
query as possible
we also selected only the necessary
columns out of these source tables
whereas the vertical query before was
selecting all of the columns and finally
one of the more interesting performance
optimizations we made was using an array
aggregation clause in bigquery where in
vertical weird had been using a row
number over Clause we use this to
identify the most recent row in a set of
rows to populate part of this UI all of
these things together ended up speeding
up the queries by 55% and the final
project that I'll talk about today is a
tweet analytics project for this project
we want to generate a report of recent
actions on entities the interesting
thing about this one is that we're
migrating from an on-premise solar
cluster into bigquery and also the
bigquery table is populated via bigquery
streaming the table is also massive it's
multiple petabytes of data in a single
table here too we partition the input
tables by time and we gave the project
many many more query slots to work with
we also schedule the projection of the
necessary columns to generate this
report out of the source tables into a
destination table again here too we also
saw a nice speed up with that the most
interesting thing that we saw here
though is we had to tune our storage set
sizes
QWERTY tables are backed by storage sets
which contain files which contain
records storage sets have a maximum size
limit so when a storage set fills up
with records it actually gets committed
and creates a metadata entry with it
associated with the table when a query
wants to run on a table it has to
process all the metadata for the
different storage sets to decide which
stored sets actually need to be accessed
if there's a lot of storage sets there's
a lot of metadata entries and processing
a lot of metadata entries can actually
slow down your query so in our use case
we worked with Google engineering to
increase the size of our storage sets
more storage sets are larger size
storage sense means fewer storage sets
overall because each one can hold more
records because there are fewer storage
sets there is less metadata entries for
a query to have to process which
actually ends up speeding up your query
a good amount when you have a high
volume with streaming inserts into a
table all of these optimizations
together resulted in 33% faster queries
for this ease case and that's the last
week's case I'm going to talk about
today I want to give a huge shout out to
everyone at Twitter cross-functionally
at Google PSO and in Google engineering
for all the help that they have given up
to today Google has helped us build
additional tools for Twitter internal
data format they've helped us build
dashboards and administration tools
they've helped us increase DML
efficiency by changing things in the
back end and they've increased limits in
GCP all over the place for us some of
the most notable ones are for VP CSC or
for the amount of data that a particular
query can process and a single go
without all of these things together we
wouldn't be near where we are today and
we're really looking forward to
continuing our adoption and growth with
bigquery at Twitter so thank you to
everyone who's been involved I'll pass
it back over to John now so he can wrap
up the rest of this presentation I hope
you found this session useful in the
some of the performance tips and
techniques as we've shared with you
today I want to thank Mike
presenter Gary who shared his best
practices of using bigquery at Twitter
and I want to thank you for watching
this session
you